hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast factors affecting the
most profitable way of allocating space
between vegetation and flowering rooms
inside a cannabis growing facility
presented by James eaves PhD professor
University of Laval
I am Cayley Bach of lab roots and I'll
be our moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
groups labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions and hits them well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble sting or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the front
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem please join me in welcoming dr.
Eve I will now turn the presentation
over to him hi Kelly thanks for that
introduction and thanks for inviting me
today like Kelly said I'm a professor at
Laval University and I'm also an
agricultural economist my research
specialty is actually investigating ways
to increase the profitability of urban
farming but a couple years ago when the
cannabis industry started really heating
up in Canada and in California I started
being invited to different cannabis
conferences to talk about my research
and so now I work I split my time
between urban farming and working with
cannabis producers to understand how
they can use technology and processes to
improve their operational efficiency
today I want to talk to you about what I
think is a sort of
appreciated topic among both researchers
and certainly among many producers and
that's the benefits or the potential
benefits of optimizing space within
indoor facility in Canada the law
requires that growers grow either in
warehouses or in greenhouses and within
that constraint that creates an
opportunity to increase yields by better
managing how you use that space for
different phases of the plant's
development and just to give you some
context about how important this is I've
given a price of seven dollars a gram
which is about the average price in
Canada right now if I want to grow or
doesn't optimize space you know and they
can lose up to eleven thousand dollars a
day and that's that's an estimate for a
small grower so this is a potentially a
really big problem or a really big
opportunity depending on the way you
look at it I like to look at it as an
opportunity because what I think it does
is that it gives the grower an
opportunity to manage their growing
strategy and the methods they use to
best utilize or create a space that
maximizes their revenues per unit of
space given their business strategy this
is a this can be really complex sort of
mathematical problem that I mean not
very complex but it can be a little
heavy to present in a presentation so
what I'm really gonna try to do today is
I'm going to use very simple mathematics
to try to give you a strong intuition
into why and how space allocation is
important in the context of growing
cannabis indoors in order to do that I
have to give you a quick
introduction into the process of growing
cannabis the different stages of growth
for those who aren't familiar with that
process then I'll use a very simple
example about the simplest I could find
or come up with to show you how changes
in allocation of space during is this
during the harvest cycle impact the
grower yields per unit of space at the
end of at the end of the process I'll
tell you how grower specific are zooming
into the presentation I'll show you how
grower specific factors impact that sort
of optimization problem and then I'll
conclude so the most common way to start
growing is to use clones alright that's
that gives the grower the ability to
control both pests and the quality of
their product I mean probably the
easiest and the most common way of
cloning it's just using cuttings and
what I mean by that is that the grower
will take a plant that they really like
that they feel really comfortable with
and that's what they cut they call it
their mother plants and they'll cut off
small branches and then they'll put that
that small branch into some sort of
medium maybe with hormones may be with
not without hormones until the branch
starts growing roots at the bottom of
the branch and then and that takes that
process takes about seven to ten days
and during that process they're the
plants being exposed to slightly less
intensive light or for at least 14 hours
a day and once the roots start cycling
at the circling at the bottom of the pot
then the plant will be transported and
transplanted into a larger pot at the
point where its transplanted the plant
is somewhere around typically around
eight inches high
the next phase is called the growth or
vegetation space or sometimes phase or
just a veggies and this is one the plant
really starts the growth process really
starts taking up as well as picking up
speed is one that when the plan this is
sucking up all types of nutrients
especially nitrogen in order to build
richer leaf structure and band stronger
branches and trunk so that eventually
the plant and you know sustain can grow
healthy buds and support those buds or
flowers during this time there the
plants put under more intense light for
at least 16 hours a day up to 24 hours a
day and this period lasts for about 1/2
between 1 and 8 weeks depending on
genetics and the growers kind of growing
strategy the the final phase is what we
call the flowering or the balloon phase
this is when the grower reduces the life
cycle to 12 hours on 12 hours off what
does that down life's life's like that
light cycle triggers response in to
plant the it simulates basically fall
the day's getting shorter and treating
the triggers a response to the plant
that causes us to start creating flowers
to start creating buds and that process
typically lasts longer than the
vegetation process it lasts about 6 to
10 weeks and during this process right
after the lighting period is switched
the plant has something that's that's
called a growth spurt right where
stretch the plant can grow significantly
really rapidly just with a no first few
weeks after switching for the flowering
cycle and by the time the harvest the
flowering cycles finish the plant can be
up to three times larger in volume than
at the end of the vegetation cycle three
times it's a little bit on the extreme
end but certainly it's it's it's
imaginable and
and I want to use kind of extreme
example for examples are gonna follow
okay so just what I want you to take
away from this is that the vegetation
period is typically shorter than the
flowering period okay and what we see in
the industry is that the vegetation
period is is the ratio of the vegetation
time to flowering time is getting
shorter and I'll kind of give you some
insights into why later on the
presentation the second thing that's
important to understand at this point
and to remember is that the flowering
plant is much larger than the bedding
plant it takes up more space and and we
don't want to admit who remember those
two points is those are going to be two
basic factors that you need to consider
in the examples that follow explaining
how rowers optimize space between
vegetation vegetation plants and
flowering plants okay so what I'm gonna
do now is going to move to the example
and the objective of this example is to
have again to show how changes in size
or differences in size and different
differences in the duration of time
between those two phases actually create
an opportunity to increase average
yields per day by changing the way we
allocate space between flowers that are
in the vegetation phase and flowers are
in their flowering phase okay so we're
gonna start with a really simple example
and this actually it's a simple example
it was actually a common example for
small growers so there's one or even I
shouldn't just say small growers often
new growers also I see a lot of
architectural plans for growers and very
often those architectural plans will
show us will show a space or an
architectural design where the same room
is
being used for both veggie vegging
plants and flowering plants so there's
one room and we're gonna assume that the
vegetation period lasts for weeks
okay and I'm gonna use this in the table
at Falls home use B as a symbol
indicating that a room is being used for
vegging plants and the flowering period
lasts eight weeks and I'll use a simple
F to indicate that phase indicate that
will of room is being used for flowering
on the room can hold up to 500 meter
square of flowering plants you know the
worst I had the maximum size at the
plants maximum size given that the room
can hold 500 pairs of those plants so
here we see I kind of made a simple
table and it shows 24 weeks of growth
right so top called the top row shows
the week the second row shows the cycle
that the room is being used for in other
words you see that for the first four
weeks the room is being used for
vegetation and then at the end of week
four the grower switches the light cycle
from say 18 hours on in six hours off to
12 hours on twelve hours off
representing the work or simulating fall
fall conditions with a plant the plants
switches into a flowering cycle and you
see that flowering cycle lasts an
additional eight weeks at the end of
eight weeks there's a harvest of five
hundred thousand five hundred thousand
grams because I think what I didn't
mention here somehow is that in the
previous slide mention that is that is
yeah sorry I did that each in each each
meter square produces one thousand grams
of flour so every meter squared of ours
produces 1,000 grams of flour of dry
flour okay so at the end of the 12-week
period we have 500,000 a year of 500 500
thousand grams okay and then we start
the the vegging cycle again I think
actually this should I mean a little
error here as you can see this actually
should be the V the benching cycle
starts again for four weeks and then
switches to a flowering cycle and then
at the end of the second flowering cycle
we have another 500 thousand grams
produced and so you see okay so what we
see is that every 12 weeks the facility
produces 500 500 thousand grams of dry
flour and if we divide that 500 thousand
grams by the number of days we see that
an average the facility is growing 5952
grams per day so next I want to show you
is that well actually let me show you
demonstrate here it's you can kind of
get a sense that the this facility is
under utilizing space because you
imagine there it's there both this room
here that's being used for vegetation a
week one is the same room that's being
used at in week five right but the
flowers that are growing during week one
are much smaller than the flowers that
are growing or the plants that are
growing during the second phase of
flowering phase so you can imagine a lot
of space that's just not being used
right and so what we want to do is find
a way to reduce that under utilization
okay and so what you'll see is the way
we can reduce it is based it by creating
more rooms okay so what we do now is
gonna have a two room example okay in
this example we're gonna take the 500
500 meter square of space and we're
gonna split it between two rooms for
e-news one room from vegetation for
vegging two flowers and then after that
vegetation cycle is done we're gonna
move those flowers into or we include
those plants excuse me into the
flowering room okay
and so that space this is just so I can
actually I'm gonna use some simple math
and the only reason doing it is just so
I can actually show you some numbers to
show you the actual increase in increase
in production so that space that's 500
meters squared is gonna be separated
between two rooms a flowering room and
vegetation room the flowering room is is
has to be larger than the vegetation
room because we don't want to waste in
space so we're gonna use a minimum
amount of space we need for vegetation
right and then we're gonna grow those
smaller plants then we're gonna move
them into another room where they're
gonna grow larger and we want to again
use the minimum amount of space we need
to grow the flowering class while using
the entire space we have right so the
flowering the flowering plants are gonna
be some factor larger than the vegging
plants in this example we're going to
assume that the flowering plant at its
maximum size is going to be three times
larger and volume than a denim bedding
plant happy its maximum size so we can
rewrite this equation here as the size
of room as is split between the
flowering room which is a time's the
bench in room plus the size of the
bedding room so then we can do a simple
calculus simple algebra we solve for the
sizes of veggie bedding room and we see
the bedroom room is equal to the total
size of the space v mu squared divided
by 1 plus a or 4 and so that we're gonna
devote one set 125 meters squared to the
vegging room and the rest of the space
is going to be devoted to the flowering
room okay so this is what that kind of
room looks like using the same Excel
spreadsheet or table so again the weeks
are on the top and on the first we see
and this is a cycle in the first room
and we see that in the first room that
first four weeks are used for vegging
alright then we move those plane
into a flowering room and those flowers
grow right and then we start in and what
we with what we've done is we
immediately start another betting cycle
and that goes for four weeks and then we
put grow for hunt and at the end of the
at the twelve weeks same twelve weeks we
have three hundred seventy-five thousand
grams produced
I actually made another error here I'm
really apologize these this whole thing
right here just to be clear this should
be should be these all so in other words
just to be clear it's like right after
the last betting period when we move the
flower the plants into the flowering
room we immediately start another
vegging period okay in here and and then
we move when we move the plants when we
move when we actually harvest the the
375 thousand grams we or we've already
started another fledging period so the
vegging room is conscious is constantly
being used right but what you see is
what happens by splitting the rooms this
way is that we've we've reduced the size
of the grain size of the harvest like
you remember for was five hundred
thousand grams meters five hundred
thousand grams produced total now is
only three hundred seventy five thousand
but what happens is after the first
harvest the harvest cycle reduces from
twelve weeks eight weeks right because
after the first because again you were
wait after we take the we we move the
plants into the from veg to flowering we
can immediately start another veg cycle
while these plants are into flowering in
the flowering room and once they're done
we don't have to wait another four weeks
we have that the plants are already that
the fetching theory is already done and
we just reload the flowering okay and
what that ends up doing is that
increases our yield from
seventy-five thousand nine hundred grams
per day to six thousand six hundred
ninety six grams per day and that's a
13% increase right just by reallocating
space so so next is okay well what about
a three room case alright what if we
devote the entire we break up a space
even further instead of having just one
flowery room we have to fire eros
okay so now we have this the total space
is split up between these two fire rooms
each of equal size each three times
larger than the bedroom okay so when we
go again Andry solve this equation we
have the equation changes slightly the
ratio changes slightly and now we what
we are our bedroom shrinks even further
to from approximately hundred
twenty-five meter square just seventy
one point four meters squared and the
flower rooms now the flowering room is
214 approximately 114 meters squared
okay and so now we see we have a new
table and we see that the vegging room
right
once one cycle is done we feed a vegging
room I mean once one the first bed cycle
is done we feed the flowering room we
immediately start another bed cycle okay
once that cycle is done we feed the
second room I once and then when the one
that one that the first room flowering
room it reaches Hara maturity we're all
ready to load it again with the product
from the vegging room and you see that
now we're where much the space is much
more highly utilized right again you see
the same sort of dynamic you see that
oh the the first
harvest which still takes 12 weeks is
now less than half the one in case right
but the the time to receive that is drop
from 12 weeks which is the case for the
one week case to four weeks right so we
have a much we have a much shorter
harvest cycle after the first after the
first harvest right so you can think of
the this loss and the first harvest that
went from 501 in case 214 in the three
bloom case as sort of an investment like
you give up you know 256 thousand grams
or your first harvest is the investment
you make in order to reduce the harvest
cycle from 12 weeks to four weeks and so
that increases the grams per day the
average grams per day from 5960
approximately from the one in case to
over seven thousand six hundred grams
per day or 20 nights an increase right
so we're using exactly the same space
but we've increased the yield by 29% and
given the prices of cannabis that's a
tremendous amount of money money for
even a small farmer and so the takeaway
here is that what we see is the the
ratio of the size of a mature flowering
plant to the size of a vegging plant
determines the sizes of the rooms right
the relative sizes of the rooms and then
the vegging time the amount of time it
takes the plants to finish their
batching cycle compared to the amount of
time it takes the plants to finish the
bloom cycle determines the number of
rooms okay and the reason I just want to
emphasize that is that what we're gonna
see in the next part
presentation is that these two this
these two factors change with all these
other far more specific characteristics
like things that are under the farmers
control right okay I'm going to talk
about individual ones in a second I just
want to keep you have you keep in mind
that that those two things are basically
driving this result driving how much you
can increase your yield by optimizing
your space allocation is impacted by all
these factors that change depending on
where you're growing what your strategy
is who your customers are things again
that are under the farmers can control
so the farm to actually manipulate those
things to try to maximize the benefits
they get from optimizing space and
oops um excuse me so the first thing is
a example we in the last example use
kind of an extreme example where the
flowering plant as added at peak size
was three times larger than the benching
plant at peak size if we assume that
instead the flowering plant is only 1.5
times the size of edging plant at his
peak then the increase in output per
unit of space per day decreases from 29%
to just 12.5% so in other words that is
like that the relative sizes of plants
is a really important factor in turning
how much you can gain from optimizing
space lots of things impact the relative
sizes or the relative size of a plant at
his bench days versus versus its bloom
or flower stage one of the most
important are just genetics plants that
have a
near the equator closer to the equator
which were our port would commonly refer
to them as sativa strands or sativa
genetics are are much larger at maturity
and have much longer flowering periods
compared to plants that evolved in
northern regions more northern regions
you can imagine kind of why because
plants that have you know down towards
equator
it's much warmer the Sun is basically
out you know it's twelve hours a day all
day long and in that cycle never changes
and so the plant can absorb can spend
more time building mass and that
increases the likelihood of propagation
okay also because it's warmer the plant
likes to get higher so and be a little
less densely it's foliage will be less
dense because it's trying to get to more
air movement that keeps its buds cooler
right but the point is you know what you
see is a much bigger growth spurt with
sativa varieties varieties that evolve
an equator than varieties like indica
that that evolved in more northern
regions these in because they are much
shorter right they have much shorter
flowering periods because just the
summer shorter and and so their growth
spurts are smaller so the the variation
size between the backsides of avenging
indica plant and the max size of a
flowering in the plant that ratios are
smaller right that's one of the reasons
growers really like indicas they like to
grow in because in indoors because they
just take less space and they have
shorter and they can have more harvest
per year because of the flowering cycles
shorter another thing that's important
spectrum right though it's light
spectrum remember I'm primarily
talking about indoor growing your
greenhouse are growing in warehouses but
this is I mean this is obviously also
true that a Sun you just have less
control of it well what we find is that
the spectrum intensity of Lights cause
has an impact on the growth spurt will
have an impact on again that the
relative size of the flowering plant to
the to the vegging plant for instance
l'eau de l'eau dl i fel i stands for
daily light integral it's the amount of
the total number of photons that the
plant is receiving over a 24-hour period
if it's not getting if plants not
getting enough light what it'll do is
it'll the plant will have this like it
will think that it's being shaded
somehow and it'll will have a growth
spurt it'll grow it'll induce it'll duce
the plant to stretch right that tends to
make it again the the final the final
plant is much longer than the plant at a
staging stage it also has some
detrimental impacts on the quality of
the plant but I won't get into that here
just because we're talking about space
allocation but the point is if you're
not using enough light we're gonna cause
this this it can cause a stretching and
that's gonna have an impact on how you
allocate space other thing is just a
spectrum blue light reduces stretching
right red light more red light tends to
increase stretching and again this is
just it's related to the you know how
the plant has evolved to respond to
sunlight and in the fall you'll see more
the Sun starts because of the spectrum
starts becoming less blue and more red
which again and with singles to the
plant
oh it's fall I need to start my
reproduction cycle and so it'll have a
it can have that it induces growth
spurts okay but again the point is
because we're using artificial lights
like here I have two spectrums this is a
spectrum a typical spectrum from
high pressure sodium light which is a
very popular though it's becoming less
popular light used in controlled
environments and this is an LED spectrum
and so you see that the grower their
choices and lights is going to impact
intensity in spectrum and that's gonna
impact how the plants how growths works
are gonna are the size of gross burps
inside these fields facilities another
factor that's important is something
called thermal period and that's just a
difference between the daytime and
nighttime temperatures or in an indoor
environment the difference between the
temperature when the lights are off and
when the lights are on
so what we've learned is what we know is
that that when as that difference
becomes greater plants that will that
difference will induce stretching them
it will do the plants to grow faster
when during the flowering period and the
reason is intuitive is is because during
the fall and fall approaches that
difference in the real world in nature
expands in its signals to the plant to
in its flowering process and stretching
process I mean what we found is that
when we reduced that difference we can
significantly reduce the amount of
stretching that occurs enabling growers
to better manage their space and of
course another thing is it's just a
level of temperature you can increase
the level of temperature and increase
the rate of growth like I'm doing an
experiment right now with a company
where I'm setting up an experiment right
now is the company where we're we're
trying to reduce the total harvest time
by a few days by increasing the
temperature rooms by three degrees so
again the some resistive takeaways is
that we can find controlling temperature
we can we can can we can control those
differences between vegging the size of
edging plants and size of flowering
plants another important factors
nutrients at different cycles at
different period
when a window plants a seed lean with
plants and a veg feeds on plants in the
flowering phase different types of
nutrients float will induce stretch
introduce more growth for instance by
adding more phosphorus in the flowering
phase we can well well that will
increase that stretching by or vice
versa you can reduce the phosphorous to
try to repeat reduce the stretching that
occurs during during during flowering
mama this is an interesting one because
of some trends we see in the industry
right now and what we've seen the
industry is something called a single
Cola sea of green and what growers are
doing is that they're just growing their
vegging their plants for one week and
then immediately swishing it to
flowering for about seven weeks so they
have about an eight week Rose cycle and
the plants together rice is really
trying to maximize the amount of dollars
created per unit space and so and that's
interesting because when we pack plans
together the leaves from one plant
create shade on the leaves of another
plant and it changes the spectrum the
light that's hitting the leaves of the
shaded plants which triggers this
mechanism in the plant that we in what
we call shade avoidance the syndrome
sort of plants tender to to realize that
are competing with other plants and then
start racing towards the light right and
so we think you know just so take away
is your spacing between plants will have
an impact on how much they grow all
right have those that that's stretching
we're talking about that impacts your
optimization space um so now like I said
so I have we you know I'm I don't have
solid data on I want to emphasize it my
data on how this
manche spaces very anecdotal at this
point because it's hard to visit the
Celebes a lot of people aren't you know
there's just a visit cell cell you need
security clearance you have to know the
growers but we have managed to visit
about nine nine facilities and we was in
it's clear that three of them are
thinking really hard about space
optimization where's the rest it appears
that they're not right or they're not
thinking about it very carefully
um I guess it just appears that way from
talking them and looking at how the how
they're they accept their rooms and as a
sanity any case nearly all the
architectural plans that we see from new
growers are are don't seem to be
accounting for increases in in
production that can happen by by
improving the way they allocate space
between flour and bedrooms so the so the
question is why right are these are they
are people ignorant about this do they
not have time to think about it or are
we missing something right so but from
talking to growers and thinking about
this problem
we definitely realize that there are
there are many other factors that impact
the optimization space right this model
becomes much more complicated for
instance one of the most important is
the time needed to manage additional
rooms right every time I start a new
room right all right I add a new room I
create labor eats I created a need for
time to move plants from the fledging
room to flowering room and and that's
costly and I don't mean costly in terms
of the dollar cost of labor
I mean costly because they say it takes
three days to break down a room
the bedding room and move the plants in
the flowering room and then we stop the
the bedding room those three days are
extremely valuable when something's
selling for $7.00 a
right so in other words that time
becomes incredibly important because it
reduces the number of harvests I have a
year right first so to give you just to
give us and an example um oh here it is
excuse me if it takes three days to
break down the betting room and restock
the flowering room um if we add those
three days to that model we did a three
room case we say okay the harvest period
takes three extra days that reduces the
benefits of moving from one room to
three rooms from 29% to just 16% and if
you go further and say okay now the
plants only 1.5 times as large the
flowering plants only one times 0.5
times as large as a veggie plant and it
takes three rooms to break down three
days to break down a room that removes
reduces the benefits from 29% sits just
1.6 percent so it's extremely sensitive
it's sensitive to time right and in that
three room in three days room three days
the breakdown room is about the amount
of time it takes to break down a
medium-sized room other factors it's
just costly to build new rooms like in
Canada so much regulation and around how
you build rooms just adding a door is
three thousand dollars all right and
then you have to add different types
security measures and so it can be
extremely really expensive to build it
basically add another wall and another
doorway all those regulations about how
the room is designed you have to have
two aisles you have two exits and so
every time you add a new room you
basically lose five feet in that room
because you have to have additional
aisle that's large enough for a
wheelchair to turn around in and so it's
so basic each time to add another a new
room you're reducing a total amount of
space you have for growing in your
facility and
this also there's issues about managing
contamination right when I'm moving
plants around from room to room if I
might be more likely to to also move a
move pests and diseases right on the
other side if I'm just using one
gigantic room if one plant becomes
infected with something it's much more
likely that it'll spread to lots of
plants versus the other case right just
have one room and I'm gonna have many
rooms and if I have a contamination in
one of those rooms it's much easier to
control okay so and this is certain or
other examines also um one very likely
reason it's just that this market is
growing so fast right now and and the
revenues are so high associated with the
revenue gets like getting plants out the
door that there's just not a very strong
incentive right now to think about
little details like space optimization I
mean they may be they optimize your
space but it's not like you're
extracting data and thinking about what
genetics are using it and what lights I
expect from there you see and how it's
gonna impact the the perfect of right
allocation of space it's more like you
know it's seven dollars a gram today six
months from now it might be five dollars
a gram let's just produce and produce
and then work and it's not like a
lettuce farmer who has their margins are
so thin they have to think about every
way they can possibly like add another
gram per unit of space like so this said
there's a weak inocentes because the
market is so hot right now and also
these are new growers a lot of a lot of
people are getting sucked into this
market that actually don't have very
strong agricultural backgrounds and so
they might not be sufficiently data
oriented there some are very
sophisticated but many aren't um
eventually they will be because thing
master prices come down the only thing
that's gonna matter is operational
efficiency so basically what I wanted to
show you
this presentation was to give you some
intuition about the opportunity that
exists here right there's a lot of like
efficiency gains that can be made from
[Music]
optimizing space and understanding how
all these different factors impact space
optimization let me give you an example
like I said you know certain growers
they prefer certain genetics there's
thousands of different varieties of
cannabis right now and they'll and and
many of them behave very differently in
terms of the way they grow and the
client or customer experience they
create um and as my customers change
right and I want to provide variety
right I either my customers are changing
so I want to provide new types of
product or my customers don't always
want to buy the same type of product
they want to have choice and so that
means that my plants are gonna change
and that means that those those factors
we discuss about like how much the plant
grows after flowering or how long the
veg cycle is relative the flowering
cycle are gonna change with genetics are
gonna change with my customers yeah my
facility doesn't change right even
though that change implies that the way
I optimize spaces should change my
facility does enters your solid walls
usually the the trays are connected to
the floor it's hard to move things
around and so one really interesting
research opportunity and just practical
opportunity for the industry is like
well how can we build facilities that
are more capable of taking advantage of
this opportunity to space optimization
opportunity that's created by by both
the plant and the growers growing
strategy that changes all the time okay
well thank you very much and I
look more to your questions thank you
doctor used for that informative
presentations dr. Edith will be
answering questions via email I would
also like to thank lab groups for making
today's education the webcast possible
where we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through June 29th
2018
you will receive an email for laggards
letting you know when the what this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon
goodbye